As we've mentioned a number of times in
this course, it's important that you
have a strategy for backing up all of
your systems. This can really save the
day when a document goes missing or
spreadsheet gets corrupted. And if you
lose all of your data on a system, you
can simply restore from your latest
backup.
There are a number of things to consider
when you're deciding on a backup
solution. One of them would be the total
amount of data that you want to back up.
It's very different backing up 100
megabytes versus 100 terabytes. What
type of backup do you want to use? We'll
go through a number of options in this
video today. What backup media do you
plan on using? Where will this
information be stored? What type of
software will be used for this backup
and perhaps more importantly for the
restoration of this data? And should you
perform this backup every day of the
week? Should it be once a week? We'll
talk about different strategies for
backups and more in this video.
If you simply want to backup every bit
of data on a system to one single backup
set, then you're going to perform a full
backup. As the name implies, this backs
up everything on your computer. So, if
you lose all of your data, you can go
back to your full backup and restore
everything to your system.
Since you are backing up every bit of
data on that computer including the
operating system, your user documents
and your applications, this is one of
the longest processes for backups. You
have to be able to transfer all of that
data off of your system and onto some
type of backup media. Because of the
long time frames associated with a full
backup, it's difficult to perform one of
these every single day. Not only does it
take a long time to perform this backup,
it's also taking up a large amount of
storage space every time you perform
this full backup.
Of course, there are other ways to
backup data instead of performing a full
backup every day. One of these methods
would be a differential backup. The
first day of a differential backup looks
identical to performing a full backup.
On that first day, you take that full
backup of the entire system. On the
second day, however, you do not take a
full backup. Every backup that occurs
after that full backup contains only
information that was changed since the
full backup. This means on the second
day, there will probably be a small
amount of data that had changed in the
last 24 hours.
On the third day, you're backing up
everything that has changed since your
full backup. On the next day, you're
also backing up everything that has
changed since that full backup. So,
you'll notice each day your differential
backup gets a little bit larger as you
begin to backup more and more changed
information.
If you need to restore from this
differential backup, you will need two
different backup sets. You will need the
full backup that you originally did, and
then you will need your last
differential backup. That will contain
everything that was there when you
started the backup process, and
everything that had changed since that
time frame.
Let's say that we take a backup every
single day, and if we'd like to
implement a differential backup, we'll
start our first backup day on Monday
with a full backup. On Tuesday, we'll
take a differential backup, which will
only be the information that's changed
since Monday. On Wednesday, we take
another differential backup. This will
obviously include some of the
information that was changed from
Tuesday, and will certainly contain
everything that has changed since the
original Monday full backup. On
Thursday, another differential backup,
which is everything that has changed
since Monday. And then in the middle of
the day on Thursday, we might decide
that we need to restore everything on
the system. To be able to restore using
a differential backup, you will need the
original full backup that we made on
Monday, and the last differential
backup, which in this case was made on
Thursday.
Another popular backup type is an
incremental backup. An incremental
backup starts the same way that a full
backup starts and starts the same way
that a differential backup starts by
taking a full backup on the first day.
But that's where things change. With an
incremental backup, we are backing up
everything that changed since the first
full backup and things that have changed
since the last incremental backup. This
means every day the backup size will be
a little bit different. It might be
larger or smaller than the previous day
depending on what may have changed
during that time frame.
To restore all of the data on the
system, you would need a full backup and
then you would need every incremental
backup that was made since the full
backup.
Let's take the same scenario where we
will perform a backup every day, but in
this case we're going to do an
incremental backup. On Monday, we start
with our full backup. On Tuesday, we
take a backup of everything that's
changed since the full backup. On
Wednesday, we backup all of the data
that's changed since the last
incremental backup. On Thursday, we also
take a backup of everything that's
changed since the last incremental
backup. This will allow us to restore
all of the most recent data to our
system.
Earlier in this video, we described a
full backup as taking a great deal of
time. But what if you could create a
full backup without actually taking a
full backup? That's the idea behind a
synthetic backup. As we've already seen,
our differential and incremental backups
take a full backup on the first day and
then take a different amount of data on
the subsequent days. A synthetic backup
will take all of this information,
combine it all together to create a full
backup from everything that you already
have. This means that you don't have to
spend more time creating a brand new
full backup on Monday. You can simply
take the backups that you already have
and create a full backup synthetically.
Since we're not taking a complete full
backup where we're transferring all of
this information across the network, we
are saving a lot of bandwidth and we're
certainly saving a lot of time. This is
a very easy way to create a full backup
from all of the incremental or
differential backups that you've already
done.
Let's now use our same scenario to
create a synthetic backup. On Monday,
the first day, we need to take a full
backup. And let's assume in this case
that this organization uses incremental
backups. You could of course create a
synthetic backup from differential
backups as well. On Tuesday, we take an
incremental backup of everything that's
changed since the last full backup. On
Wednesday, we take another incremental
backup that takes everything that's
changed since Tuesday. On Thursday,
another incremental backup which takes
everything that has changed since
Wednesday. And then on Friday, we put
all of this information together. We
only take the latest version of files
that we've backed up to create the
synthetic full backup by simply
combining together all the backup sets
that we already have.
Here's a summary of these different
backup types. We'll start with the full
backup, which obviously takes a backup
of all of the data. If you want to back
up this data, it takes quite a bit of
time, so we'll put that on the high
category. But restoring everything means
that we're simply copying over all of
the data, so it has a relatively low
restore time due to that single backup
set. A differential backup is going to
back up all data since the last full
backup. Since each day is only backing
up the information that was changed
since the last full backup, we can mark
this as a moderate backup time and a
moderate restore time. One of the
advantages of course to differential is
that restore time is kept very low
because we only need two backup sets,
the full backup and the last
differential backup. An incremental
backup copies all new files and files
that have been modified since the last
backup. This means that our backup time
frames every day are relatively low, but
when we need to restore, the backup time
is relatively high. That's because we
will need the full backup and all of the
incremental backups to be able to
perform a full restoration.
And since a synthetic backup contains
exactly the same information as a full
backup, all data on that system is
backed up with a synthetic backup
process. Since a synthetic backup is
creating a full backup from backup sets
that are already existing, it has a
relatively low backup time and a
relatively low restore time because
everything is in one single full
synthetic backup.
You may think that after performing your
backups, that your job is done. But in
reality, your job is only half done. We
know that we've backed up the data, but
are we able to restore the data? That is
an important step of any backup process.
It might be a good idea to simulate some
type of recovery testing. You can pick a
particular document that is stored on a
particular server and go through the
process of restoring just that document
to your recovery system.
This will either confirm that our backup
and restoration process is working or it
might discover that there is a problem
with the restoration process that we
need to resolve. Once we have our
restored file, we can test it and make
sure that everything in that document is
exactly the same as the original
document that was backed up.
It's usually a good idea to perform
audits of your backup process. You never
know what documents may have changed or
what part of the backup process may have
been altered, so checking this on a
regular basis should be part of your
normal processes.
Now that we've backed up our data and
we've tested the restoration process, we
need to think about how we're going to
perform that restoration. There are
different options that you can choose
during the restoration process. One of
these would be to restore everything
exactly in the same location where it
originated. This is an in-place
restoration where you are overriding any
data that might already be on that
system with the information that's
contained in the backup. For example, if
you were performing a re-imaging of a
system using those backup files, you're
very often performing an in-place
restoration.
But, you might also be concerned that
your in-place restoration might
overwrite important data that has been
changed since the backup was made. In
that case, you might choose to perform
your restoration to an alternate
location. This restoration option
restores the files to a separate
location instead of overriding anything
that might already be on that original
system. That way, you can maintain all
of your existing files and then have the
original backup stored in a different
location that you can then copy over
later if you need to.
Many organizations will perform on-site
backups. This means both the backup
systems and the data are contained
within the same facility. This gives you
high bandwidths between the backup
system and the data itself. And if you
need to have access to those backup
tapes for restoration, all of that
information is locally available. Since
all of your data and systems are already
running at this location, you usually
don't have to pay anything extra to
maintain your backup systems at that
same site.
Some organizations will opt for an
off-site backup where the information is
stored somewhere different than your
location. You're transferring data
usually over an internet connection or
high-speed wide area network link.
Since your data is located somewhere
outside of your current location, you're
now protected against any disaster that
might occur to your existing building.
If your building becomes a victim of a
fire or a flood, you can simply move
everything to a different site and
restore all of that offsite backup data
from anywhere in the world. There are
obviously advantages and disadvantages
to both onsite backups and offsite
backups, and many organizations will
often use both of these to some degree
so that they can take advantage of those
backups in either of those scenarios.
We often think of backups as a single
monolithic piece of data, and that piece
of data has no relationship with any
other data or other backups that you're
doing. But in reality, you're often
taking different backups that contain
different data, and you're taking these
backups on different days or different
weeks.
One common strategy for timing and
layering these backups is called GFS.
That stands for grandfather, father,
son. We start with creating the
grandfather backup. This would be a
single full backup that occurs once a
month. This would be 12 monthly full
backups in a single year. And these
might be the backups that we send off to
offline storage so that we can retrieve
those if something happens to our
building. Now we can focus on a weekly
backup, and if you're doing weekly
backups, you might need four or five of
those in a single month. We refer to
these backups as the father backup. So
if our grandfather backups are once a
month and our father backups are once a
week, then obviously our son backups are
going to occur every single day. So we
might have 31 daily incremental or 31
daily differential backups that we refer
to as the son backup.
Here's an example of a month, and you
can see where I've overlaid sun backups,
father backups, and grandfather backups.
You can also change the time frames
associated with these rotations. Perhaps
the sun backup is taken every hour, your
father backup is taken every day, and
the grandfather backup is taken every
week.
On my calendar though, I've created a
different schedule where the grandfather
is taken on the 31st of each month. The
father backup takes place every Monday
and then the sun backups are taken every
Monday through Friday.
Regardless of the type or interval
between these backups, we also need to
think about where these backups will be
stored. And one good strategy that many
organizations will follow is the 3-2-1
backup rule. With this rule, three
copies of your backup data should always
be available. This means you could have
one primary copy and two backups or any
other combination so that we can get to
three separate and unique copies of this
backup data. The number two in the 3-2-1
backup rule is two different types of
media. Your backup could be taken on a
local storage drive, on tape backup, or
NAS. So, if your organization is
following the 3-2-1 backup rule, they
may be storing one copy of the backup
data on a local drive and other copies
of the backup data on tape. And the one
in the 3-2-1 backup rule says that at
least one copy of these backups should
not be on site, they should be stored
somewhere else off site. This means you
could store the information in an
offsite storage facility, you might
store it as part of your cloud backup,
but that information is stored outside
of your local building so that if you
ever need to access that data in a
disaster, you know that it's stored
somewhere safe.